hey guys welcome to max tech and in this
video i'm gonna be doing perhaps the
most important gaming test to ever
happen in the iphone's history i'm gonna
be testing out if using low power mode
on the iphone 13 pro or 13 pro max is a
viable option for iphone gamers to get
both awesome performance and much better
battery life at the same time and before
you call me crazy for believing that
something like that would actually be
possible let me explain myself in my
crazy long 25 minute long one week
review of the iphone 13 pro max which
you should definitely check out if you
haven't already i showed you guys some
incredibly interesting a15 chip testing
done by geeker1 on youtube he basically
showed that the 5 core gpu on the a15 is
so powerful that while using low power
mode the 13 pro max outperformed the
snapdragon 888 chip by 17
while using almost three times less
power giving it insanely good
performance per watt while using low
power mode and then i recently read an
article on notebookcheck.com written by
sanjeev where he mentioned that low
power mode most likely completely
disables the performance cores so the
entire phone will run on just the four
efficiency cores obviously saving a lot
of battery life but not only that the
a15s geekbench performance scores while
using low power mode are still able to
compete with flagship android phones
under full performance so because of all
of that i had this crazy idea what if
you could play games with low power mode
turned on and still get a solid 60 fps
while not dealing with display dimming
issues and saving battery life all at
the same time essentially being the most
perfect gaming mode the iphone has ever
seen well that's exactly what i'm gonna
find out in this video because this
iphone 13 pro max is completely charged
and set to 80
brightness so i'm gonna play some games
for a full hour to see how much battery
life it consumes and then i'm gonna
recharge the phone back up to a hundred
percent and play another full hour but
this time while using low power mode and
i'll be testing to see if there are any
performance drawbacks or differences in
display dimming and then after that hour
we'll see if it actually saves battery
life or not so with that said let's
begin with some call of duty mobile all
right so as you guys can see just to
confirm we're at 100 battery life 80
brightness bluetooth is off and we are
in call of duty so let's go ahead and
unplug and let's start the test we are
sitting at 144 so an hour from now we're
gonna see how much battery life we're
left with all right so here we are one
of the things i do want to point out is
the new notch is a little bit smaller
but it doesn't really make a difference
because it's still there and i do love
the new speakers on the 13 pro max
they're just
so good
[Music]
all right let's go man
oh snap
oh
are you serious i didn't get them so far
performance no issues at all of course
someone's shooting at me
oh he's up there
got him
all right they're probably gonna be over
here somewhere
someone was behind me man
oh you're trying an iphone bro get out
of here
oh
oh two on one
performance perfect 60fps
oh get out of here bro no issues at all
boom
no issues with the performance perfect
60. of course
little power mode is off right now so
we're not gonna really see any issues
yet oh man
you dead and you did where are all the
bad dudes
oh you did oh snap are you dude these
guys got to be bots man are you serious
i know you like to be up there man
oh you're are you serious i'm gonna
throw a drone in there man watch this
oh snap at you
boom
oh that's it
that was easy
no issues with performance at all i
definitely say that i love the more
immersive display
yeah daddy
is he trying to knife me try me bro try
me
you got him
oh footsteps
boom
oh two guys on the left right here
[Music]
that wasn't mine all right watch i'm
gonna get this dude watch this watch
this
i'm gonna get you too oh are you serious
oh what all right watch this what's this
what's this i'm gonna throw it right at
somebody's face all right so no
performance issues perfect 60fps the
entire time as expected with this
flagship phone all right now let's try
out pokemon
unite
this is one of my first times playing
this game but i'm
definitely excited the settings are set
to the highest quality 60fps by the way
no display dimming at all all right we
fighting boys these are fighting words
right here
okay oh that's me man
we going in boys
boom
oh it goes through them
okay this is a fun game man
so you can see the fps counter up at the
top basically getting a really nice
solid 60 i mean it stays at 59.
you dead boy
give me that give me that boom wow this
game is fun are you serious man wow oh
dude this is like the
big dude man
you mine yeah you dude
all right i'ma chase you all the way to
your base man
wow this guy is good man whoever this is
man
oh run oh
oh
he had me man
all right performance perfect as
expected not even a single drop of
display dimming so far and i'm playing
at 80 brightness which is basically
usually what everyone would be playing
in even like a bright lit room so
win
for the kill boys let's go
boom
all right we earned it it's interesting
that there's no items in here you know
like league of legends wild rift you got
items a lot of them
but here
there are no items
oh watch there's another guy over here
check this out
dead all right this is gonna be scary
let's go
boom oh
i'm so dead guys
[Music]
nice perfect
perfect fps 60 no issues no dimming no
nothing
as expected
look at that
14
not bad all right that was fun with that
said let's actually test out another
game that is similar to this wild
rift
and now we're in wild rift i'm going to
set the frame rate to 60 and graphics
quality to ultra man the speakers on
this new iphone 13.
so good
oh riven i used to play riven
on pc league all the time riven's
hardened around man
oh come on get out of here
i mean come here
nice good job guys let's crank cranking
it up
[Music]
oh come on
that's fine that's fine all right i
don't know if you guys can see but the
fps counter perfect 60
the entire time no it's just oh i got my
all dude careful bros
oh you're serious
[Music]
but i haven't played this game forever
hey take him
all right let's take this turret forget
these dudes man
guys look out they're coming in hot
[Music]
oh no
oh
i like barely made it out there
oh i got a dude
oh no
so far guys no issues at all still no
dimming in this game still perfect 60fps
[Music]
i'm out of here boys
apparently
what oh i'm starting to feel the phone
heat up a little bit now
that's what i'm talking about yeah oh
oh there you go i need that
so the phone's heating up but still no
issues with performance or dimming so
that's good
yes
enemy team surrendered
good job guys yes
all right perfect gameplay guys just
like i said before a million times all
right now with that game out of the way
let's play some pub g
mobile there you go so 60fps everything
that's super smooth man wow some weird
glitches
is that like lag or something all right
i see somebody watch the spot
oh you're dead but
yeah i mean this game is running fine
too no issues
see you dude
got him
oh we just dimmed guys it's been one
hour of playing those four different
games and we only had dimming in this
one so let's check out
our battery life 88
battery life after one hour as you can
see 244
exactly one hour after i'm gonna go
ahead and recharge this phone i'm gonna
let it cool off and i'm gonna rerun
everything in low power mode all right
there we go we're finally finished
charging you can see a hundred percent
and now let's turn on that low
power mode
and let's run the gaming test again
starting with call of duty mobile still
nice and bright man still
perfectly smooth
get out of here perfectly smooth 60
still in low power mode you dead boy
oh
later
later nerds
oh i don't see him i don't see him
oh no where is he at
oh
footprints ah all right i'm bad watch
this what's this
oh
oh come on let me let me get him let me
get him
take that
bye-bye
dude he's fast man
no
all right that first round
literally didn't notice any performance
drawbacks at all perfect 60
no stuttering
nothing
with low power mode turned on crazy
let's get into the next game that is
pokemon unite
let's do it again with this game let's
see
what we get for performance
what is this future sight man
why did i get future sight i don't want
that anyway guys look at that fps
counter it's stuck at 59 fps basically
60
at all times and ain't moving even in
low power mode man of course this is
like a pretty easy game i'd say but hey
man
boom
[Music]
oh no run
[Music]
dude you got no chance man
let me just drop these off here
oh come on serious
oh
that was like a lux
laser blast man guys low power mode
i have not seen it go down it's insane
even in all these like group matches and
stuff crazy so good so good
he just one shot me
he one shot me
what man i thought this game was like
you know easy and stuff
dude you can't run for me bro
all right here's the big boy right here
this guy don't mess around but he's dead
watch this try and hit me try and hit me
you can't you can't hit me man
you're dead
yes
oh
this is an entertaining game this is
like the only guy who could like
potentially like even try to kill me
dude watch one hit one hit kill
no performance issues at all the first
two games let's go ahead and jump into
some wild
rift
league of legos i'm actually quite
shocked guys those first two games no
performance issues at all no drop frames
no stuttering in low power mode man so i
go in front of them and i sweep
let me get out of here
warrior spirit man
ah
not worth it not worth it all right so
i've noticed still 60 fps i don't know
if you can read that or not it's really
really tiny but we still have 60 fps
guys
we got him boys
[Music]
oh double kill
finally it's interesting even in these
uh big group fights
i'm not noticing the fps go down ever
guys kill that turret please oh we good
baby let's go let's go
oh no yeah
that was so good
oh man that's impressive man alright
we're back playing some pub g and the
first time we did see some dimming so
let's see if under low power mode if
it's using less wattage or the
performance cores are turned off if we
don't get dimming that'd actually be
really amazing if we don't get any
dimming so we'll see
all right what's this
come on
[Music]
oh i just noticed some dimming again
guys
this game did dim
oh dude he saved me yep so i did notice
dimming it did them down just right now
so i wonder if pubg is one of the more
demanding games out there i guess
get in loser we're going shopping oh
what's up dude let's go all right guys
i've been playing pubg for a while and i
don't know i'm not noticing like drop
frames or anything it's doing really
really good so far so i'm happy
i'm happy i guess after these four games
not having issues the only question is
are we saving any battery life what if
it's exactly the same as it was before
oh there you go
[Music]
all right guys it has been an hour as
you can see 4 41 exactly an hour and
here's a moment of truth no performance
issues at all basically break 60 the
entire time
now
let's see how much battery life we're
left with
92 percent
hey it's not like super crazy good but
92
versus 88
that's basically four extra percent that
we're not losing after a full hour of
gameplay with low power mode on at 80
brightness
that is actually a really good
difference because if you play for
multiple hours this is gonna add up to
some good battery life savings i'm
impressed
92 instead of 88
that's pretty good alright so there you
guys go that was two hours of gaming
with charging in between and i think we
have finally answered our original
question
yes
low power mode is viable for 60 fps
gaming because i did not notice any
performance issues no stuttering no drop
frames basically great 60 fps solid
60fps on all four of those games no
issues i only had the dimming issues in
pubg the other games were totally fine
i'm actually surprised 92 that we're
left with instead of 88
now i know from now on literally
everybody with an iphone 13 pro or pro
max should be using low power mode for
gaming especially pokemon unite whatever
wild rift call of duty i am blown away
by how good this is performing because
with those performance cores turned off
the efficiency cores alone are able to
run this
just fine and with a down clock gpu
using much less power like geekerwan
showed us it's still able to destroy
these games run them at solid 60 fps so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video and
definitely share your thoughts on low
power mode gaming down in the comment
section below definitely click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]